it's tense on the streets of Goma
police are maintaining a strong presence
since at least 43 people were killed in
protests against the U.N Mission here
known as monosco over escalating
violence in the region
the protest was organized by a Christian
religious sect and the U.N forces
accused of doing nothing to provide
safety against violence carried out by
Rebel groups in the area the security
situation is getting worse
foreign
what is happening in our country is very
sad as at the same time we fight for a
peaceful country we realize that our
leaders don't share the same vision with
us so many people have lost their lives
because of ongoing conflicts we don't
have peace in this country and we're now
living like foreigners
human rights groups accuse the ministry
of using excessive force the government
has been meeting relatives of the dead
and missing and loved ones have now been
given the right to identify the Dead
as the victim's relatives we were very
clear to the government that those
responsible must be held to account we
also insisted on the right to access the
bodies of our relatives as it's six days
since they were killed we are yet to
access their bodies for a dignified
funeral for now this is a good move
senior military and security Personnel
have been recalled to the capital
the military governor of this province
here with me has been recalled back to
Kinshasa for a consultation two police
Colonels including one from the
intelligence Department have also been
recalled to Kinshasa for consultations
one of the largest and costliest UN
peacekeeping forces established in 1999
to help protect civilians from violence
the question being asked is it capable
of doing so
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera